you don't know so many things I was
miscast for that part you know it was
the 15 year old kid it was supposed to
be written for and I was I think pushing
30. well I spent five weeks
suffering and starving myself and doing
all this stuff you know why you're
afraid when you're alone this is very
few people in movie history that are
cooler than Bruce but I remember when we
went to the premiere of The Sixth Sense
he he just was again like just kept
hugging me and saying you did so good to
be standing there that vulnerable for me
um in a scene like that which was a
really big moment in my career you know
to be across from him and knowing he had
my back it meant the world to me Donny's
memorable performance helped kick off
his acting career
and on blue
blood restaurant tour has another side
gig hosting ID's True Crime show very
scary people are you a true crime buff
I'm a fan of Forensic Files okay so
Forensic Files was my show for years I
think because of Blue Bloods actually I
think because I play a detective I think
it
created this opportunity for me to do
this
89. the Trailside killer just the name
of it is think of how many people go
walking on trails and hiking and stuff
just the name alone me too uh Jenny and
I go bike riding and and do walks on
these trails along a river near our home
it's frightening
one victim who survived an attack was
Lisa rinna's mom Lois her mother was his
first victim and only one of two people
to survive his attacks you were lucky I
was very lucky you were lucky yeah I I
should not even be here you shouldn't
even be here I know
you and Jenny watch Housewives
we do what are your cities cheese
Beverly Hills I'm Atlanta we both do
Orange County
[Music]